Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I
am going to explain an Australian
science fiction thriller film called “I
Am Mother”. Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in a dystopian
future when human beings have gone extinct.
Before their extinction, scientists had activated
a bunker as a backup plan to repopulate the earth.
The bunker is run by an AI robot called Mother.
She is given the responsibility to sort through
several human embryos and raise an efficient
human being who can be the guardian to upcoming
generations. At the beginning of the movie, Mother
goes through sixty-three thousand human embryos
and chooses a healthy one to raise. She places it
in the gestation chamber, an advanced device that
develops an embryo into a baby in only twenty-four
hours. As she waits for the baby to develop
in the artificial womb, gunshots are heard
outside the facility. She returns the next
day and brings the newborn baby girl out of
the womb. The scene is followed by a montage
of Mother raising the child. She watches Daughter
walking for the first time, nurtures her when she
cries and loves her dearly. In their free time,
Daughter and Mother make origami together. Mother
even teaches her to dance, cook, and fight.
When Daughter grows up to an appropriate age,
Mother introduces her to the other embryos and
tells her about her purpose in the world. A few
more years later, Daughter turns into a teenager.
She often watches videos of humans on her tablet.
Although she is one of them, she is fascinated by
their nature. One day, when a technical problem
arises in Mother’s hand, she easily fixes it.
This makes Mother realise she has done a good job
raising Daughter. Everyday for an hour, Mother
teaches Daughter about morals and ethics. She
gives her hypothetical questions to test her
morality. Her primary aim is to familiarise
Daughter with the concept of humanity. Soon, she
will have to attend a final test that will show
the efficiency of Mother’s upbringing.
One night, Daughter has a hard time falling
asleep so she watches videos of humans on her
tablet. Suddenly, the power cuts off. She goes
outside looking for Mother and finds that she is
also out of power. She finds a broken cable to be
the cause of the power loss. As she brainstorms
what might have caused it, she hears a mouse
squeaking. Daughter has never seen a live animal
before. She excitedly sets a mousetrap and fixes
the cable. While waiting for the power to come
back, she catches the mouse and inspects it in
fascination. After charging up, Mother finds her
with the animal and takes it away. The mouse’s
presence means a rupture in the airlock system of
the bunker which worries her. She claims that the
air outside the bunker is highly toxic which
can kill humans instantly. Following that,
she takes measures to ensure the air inside has
not been contaminated. Since the mouse is also
a potential carrier of the contamination, she
incinerates it, against Daughter’s protests.
A few days later, they celebrate Daughter's
birthday. At dinner, a curious Daughter asks
Mother if humans can somehow survive outside
the bunker. The mouse’s existence has made her
question mother’s teachings. Mother simply replies
that she knows there are no humans outside,
and since she has never been wrong, she declares
it a fact. Later that day, Daughter hears a noise
coming from the airlock of the facility. She
goes near to check but doesn’t see anything
from the first door. When the noise gets louder,
she puts on a hazmat suit and opens the door.
As she moves closer to the second one, she hears
a human female yelling for help claiming that she
has gotten shot by a droid. Daughter quickly
gets a hazmat suit for the woman to help her.
She closes the first hatch to maintain a safe
distance, then opens the entrance, letting her in.
When the door opens, Mother is alerted. The woman
begs her to not tell Mother about her arrival.
Daughter is sceptical because she has never hidden
anything from her. Mother arrives but doesn’t see
the injured woman as she stays hidden in
the airlock. When inquired what happened,
Daughter claims that she accidentally opened
the entrance. As a punishment for her mistake,
she is asked to take the final test right then.
Mother brings her to a classroom and gives her the
tablet with the questions. After she leaves,
Daughter abandons the test and goes to see the
woman. She finds her unconscious because of her
injury. She goes through her belongings just to
be safe and finds a gun in it. She then wakes the
woman up and offers her water. As the woman opens
her mask to drink it, Daughter protests about the
contamination. It is then revealed to her that
there is no contamination in the outside world and
Mother has been lying to her this entire time.
Daughter hides the woman in a part of the
bunker before Mother can see them. She then
goes to collect the required medicines from the
infirmary. In the meantime, Mother finds the
poison mask in the airlock. The woman sees Mother
throwing her poison mask in the incinerator.
Frightened, she checks for the gun
in her bag but doesn’t find it.
When Daughter returns, the woman sneaks up on her
and asks her about the gun. She refers to Mother
as a droid and wants the gun to protect herself
from her. Mother is surprised when she reaches the
classroom and finds Daughter missing. She sees the
woman holding Daughter and sprints towards them.
The woman manages to shoot her once but the
bullet doesn’t do any harm. She grabs the
woman and overpowers her easily. Daughter tries
stopping her, claiming that the only reason the
woman is here is because she needs their help.
Mother understands the problem and takes the
injured woman to the infirmary. However, she
doesn’t allow Daughter to come in with her.
Following that, Mother interrogates the woman
while dressing her wounds but doesn’t get any
answers. After she is done, she tells Daughter
that she lied to her about the contamination
to keep her safe from the dangers of the outside
world. Daughter doesn’t know what to think of the
revelation. Later that day, Daughter goes through
the woman’s belongings again and finds a book
with several sketches of people. She goes to the
woman and inquires about it. But the woman doesn’t
say anything suspecting that Mother has sent her
to question her. When Daughter defends her Mother
the woman tells her that droids have
done horrible things to humans.
Later, Daughter apologises to Mother for letting
the woman in. Mother lovingly makes her understand
the consequences and forgives her. The woman's
health gets worse but she doesn’t trust Mother to
perform surgery on her. Hence, Daughter takes the
initiative and takes the bullet out successfully.
When the woman wakes up from the surgery, Daughter
gives her some food which she devours. The two
talk as Mother watches them from afar. The
following day, the woman tells her that the
sketches in the book are her family members. She
asks Daughter to keep everything she is about to
say a secret from Mother. She then tells her about
the survivors' camp in the mines where she was
brought up. Daughter insists that the facility has
enough resources to help the people from the camp,
so they should bring them here. However, the
woman instead wants Daughter to join them in
the camp. Later, Mother informs Daughter that
the bullet she found from inside the woman
was identical to one from her gun. So, she
suspects her own kind had shot her.
Daughter then finally takes the test and
passes with flying colours. As a gift,
Mother lets her pick any embryo to raise next.
The two patiently wait for the infant to be born.
Later, the woman asks Daughter to check the
bullets herself and confirm who shot her, humans
or the droids. She does as said and finds out that
the bullets are completely different, meaning that
Mother is lying to her yet again. While she is
at it, she also finds documents labelled for
embryo number two. She goes through the files and
realises that she is not the first baby produced
in the facility. Some of the other subjects are
labelled “failed”. She then checks the incinerator
to find the remains of a human jaw. She also
discovers a document that says the subject was
aborted. Shocked that her Mother killed the other
babies, she no longer trusts her. She runs to the
woman and tells her about her findings. Daughter
then makes up her mind to run to the camp with
the woman. However, she wants her brother to
be born first so she can take him as well.
The following day, Daughter collects supplies for
their escape but Mother catches her in the act.
Mother fools her by acting like she doesn’t know
about her plan and takes her to the kitchen. She
eventually locks her there and goes to the woman
to ask her about her true motive. Meanwhile,
Daughter manages to break the glass door by
spraying a chemical on it. The woman and Mother
get into a fight but Mother gets distracted
when Daughter sets off the fire alarm.
The woman then finds Daughter and convinces
her to run away without her brother.
When Mother tries to stop them, the woman grabs
Daughter hostage and threatens Mother to open
the door for them. Mother obliges as she doesn’t
want Daughter to get hurt. The two finally escape
and run outside. However, the barren land
and the bizarre reality of the outside world
angers Daughter and she attacks the woman. The
woman insists they need to find cover as soon
as possible and the two start to run again.
They are followed by human killing droids and
narrowly escape to get to their destination. The
woman informs Daughter that the droids harvested
corn six months ago. Before that, humans could
hardly breathe. They reach a beach with massive
cargo containers. At first, the Daughter is
mesmerized by the beauty of the sea but then
she realizes the “camp” the woman was talking
about is the cargo containers. The woman finally
comes clean and says that the people at the camp
started getting crazy because of the lack of food,
so she had fled from there years ago. The
Daughter is shocked and regrets coming with her.
Without thinking much about it, she flees back
to the facility again. However, at the entrance,
she encounters several droid guards who hold her
at gunpoint. When she mentions Mother, they let
her go inside without further questioning.
Mother is glad she is safe and invites her to
come closer to look at her brother. When she
calms down, Mother finally explains to her
the true purpose of her existence. It turns out
that before Daughter, she raised several humans
and let them free in the outside world. But she
failed to consider that they might turn evil and
fight among themselves. When her children started
to threaten the second extinction of humanity,
she took measures to stop them and appointed the
droids. Starting then, she decided to raise humans
who are ethical, like Daughter herself.
As the two look at the newborn lovingly,
Daughter asks her about the human remains she
had found. Before Mother can explain herself,
she holds the baby and tries to get away from
the facility by trapping Mother. The droids
outside get notified and start cutting through
the entrance door. Daughter points a gun at Mother
asking her to tell the other droids to retreat.
Mother explains that she and other droids share
the same vision and consciousness. She then tells
Daughter that she can either leave the facility
without her brother or help her raise him.
However, Daughter insists that Mother has already
done her task by raising the Daughter. She wants a
chance to show her capabilities to her by raising
the child on her own. Suddenly, the droids stop
cutting through the entrance. Mother asks Daughter
to disable her as she has fulfilled her purpose.
Daughter shoots at her CPU, finally killing her.
She takes on the responsibility to save humanity
from extinction. We then see the woman meet
a droid who looks just like mother. It tells
the woman that she has fulfilled her purpose,
suggesting that she is also one of the mother’s
children who was presumably appointed to help
her test Daughter’s potential. In the end,
Daughter is seen singing to her baby brother
and checking on other embryos.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.